one extraordinary moment was when in
1988 20 years ago I conducted the first
auction ever conducted in Moscow since
after the 1917 evolution and that was in
the early days when the Pollock little
changes took place was a glasnost and
perestroika days that we've organized
that sale and at the time Russians were
just spectators and the collectors were
American and Western Europeans now we 20
years later the situation has evolved
enormously where the Russian collectors
are some of the key players in the
international art market and the art
market has become much much more global
than it was 20 years ago so that's
definitely a moment that I will always
remember fondly with because it was such
a watershed moment in the history of art
in Russia in particular but whenever I
sell something truly unique it's
something exciting I mean as chief
auctioneer at Sotheby's I handled many
extraordinary sales I was the one of the
auctioneer's during the sale of Jack in
NASA's Kennedy I was one of the
auctioneers in the sale of the Duchess
of Windsor jewels I was auctioneer and
many house sales in the stately homes in
Italy in Germany so each time it was
really really exciting but I think my
most exhilarating moments have been with
Phillips when we have every season
introduced new artists that have never
been sold at auction before and have
really built up interest in the
secondary market for those artists and
have really contributed to making some
careers a lot of the artists that we
have introduced to have now become
mainstays in the international
contemporary market and when we started
being very interested in artists like it
prints his works were selling like
around thirty to seventy thousand
dollars meanwhile his works sell up to
10 million dollars each he had a big of
retrospective at the Guggenheim Museum
of Art so it's
very exciting to see that we have in our
own way contributed to some of the
artists that we most strongly believe in
really becoming worldwide household name